hi guys what's up my name is Dave war
and we're going to talk about bathroom
etiquette I know sometimes we don't want
to talk about but it's something we
gotta talk about it's something that I
know it's not mentioned a lot but
there's certain things that you need to
know about handling your bathroom
responsibly
no one can create a viral video and
anyone that says to you that can make a
viral video it's gonna be lighters like
you cannot reverse engineer a viral
video 72 hours of video uploaded to
YouTube every minute less than three
percent of videos upload to you to go
over 1,000 views hi my name is David wah
and I'm an entertainer living in Los
Angeles I've been given seven chances to
create a viral video this is my
adventure and I invite you to come on
with me can I go viral can we tell you
what I all want to like Tara okay go
there we go I was awesome she's so
naughty she's so naughty yeah yeah Oh
haven't used it before but now I'm
trying Rogaine how to use it for black
men follow me and I'll show you how to
use rogaine for black men you don't want
your stuff to be ending up like Sherman
Helmsley you don't want it goof going
George Jefferson you want a nice spray
lather around around if you do it like
this on the side you're going to have
you're gonna lose it like like all right
here you don't want to have Uncle Phil
from fresh prince of bel-air for so many
people who might not know you wanted to
get it you want to get all in here like
a sweet lather um that's basically it
let me come in there come on in real
quick you want to have carpeting on your
floor this is perfect carpeting on your
floor black hides it you want a nice you
a woman opens it up BAM this is this is
what it is everyday is kind of different
when I shower I take care of the
business when I shower with a bit is all
here business what I mean is basically
again like at night you want to get like
good good products like dial st. Ives
women can tell the difference in your
skin because your skin's got to be soft
and supple as I just learned that word
in my new vocab that work supple skin
you want to have soft and supple skin
and then
for all races right here stretch marks
cocoa butter formula this is this is
this is the truth right here this right
here people if you like 300 pounds 200
pounds one I don't care how many pounds
you are you want to cover some good
stretch marks this is it right here
cocoa butter guaranteed formula Michelle
Obama uses this all the times Michelle
Obama uses it if she gives it the step
of approval that mean is good for you it
works strong on Ashley skin right now
especially during the Cold time this is
what you need um I go to my bathroom I
just I just do my regular basics in my
bathroom a good bathroom is a healthy
bathroom it's like you gotta feel like
you're at home and that's what you want
to create when you got you you got your
in your bathroom um I just hate when
people brush their teeth and then put a
lot of [ __ ] on the on the on the on the
mirror like just if you can't be just if
your teats yellow there's no way you're
going to perfect them making it white by
brushing harder you got to get a nice
little a nice little gentle brushes in
here in here like this like this yeah
like this I can even show you if you
want to come to my crib i'll show you
how to brush your teeth that's how it is
key deodorant always do it always do it
Chafin gots to get the baby powder the
baby powder is key if you're Chafin
seriously grown people they still change
not only babies chase adults chiptune
baby part of the pink one this is
amazing this is we just
smell that that's just beautiful right
there um but this is what we do have in
the past and this is how we this is
vacuum etiquette always have tissue
because lady's not gonna try to blow
their nose with toilet tissue you and
just don't seem right so Kleenex is the
brand that I always use I love Kleenex
and people you gotta floss floss you
can't be walking around with popcorn in
the middle of your teeth or corn and the
million to you know how hard that is
always always do that and yeah that's
pretty much it I mean it's sort of
things that I don't do like if I'm in
the bathroom and I gotta pee I step out
I step out and use the bathroom I know
some people who hate to do it but would
you would you take a dump in your toilet
and your in your bathroom I mean in your
in your shop what you wouldn't do that
so basically that's that's pretty much
it I don't know where else to do you
want to have clean towels i want you to
use white tiles because people could
tell how clean they are white tiles is
perfect and in a bathroom you don't want
to do any light if you do read you do
green make sure the wall is it matches i
got you've got it that's bathroom like
the whole thing just making sure
everything matches and looks great so
yeah that's Oh medicine cabin that's not
a thing listen you gotta buy chlamydia
herpes all that stuff you don't want to
put your STD medication in the medicine
cabinet cuz you never know I mean I know
it's a big it's just a big no-no you
don't want to do that any type of type
yeah rashes you don't want to put it in
the medicine cabinet doesn't know you
put it in the bedroom so they can't see
it but that's just a side note for some
people who are you know battling some of
those other stuff just want to help you
guys out just it's just this whole thing
is about back and etiquette that's
basically it just bathroom etiquette you
just want certain things do you want to
put out this is the snake this is what
this video is called back and etiquette
that yeah certain things you want to
leave out in the bathroom certain things
you don't want to put out because it's
going to be questionable so yeah always
have some antibacterial soap in the
bathroom people feel safe about that so
yeah I said bathroom etiquette you know
not everybody can use matches to take
away older you can just invest in these
people is just 99 cents at the 99-cent
store if you ask me how much
how much is 99 cents it's 99 cents 99
pennies that's all you got to do people
this just make an investment join me
David war for the next episode of can I
go viral well I was soon attempt to make
a viral YouTube video